[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the kreski auditorium if you
will please take your seats we will be
starting momentarily we request that you
make sure all cell phones and pagers are
turned off and also please note that all
audio and video recording is prohibited
please limit any flash photography to
just the first 1 minute of the
presentation ladies and gentlemen please
welcome MIT president Charles vest
thank you
want to welcome everyone to today's
discussion and presentation by
Microsoft's bill gates I think one of
the first things you'll observe that is
in the old days the academic used to
come out in a sweater to introduce the
corporate leader in the pinstripe suit
today we're going to reverse that role
and I don't think that will surprise
anyone
and then again bill is not your typical
CEO in fact he is not a CEO as you may
know he is the chief Software Architect
of Microsoft and he is indeed here today
to discuss with you some of the grand
challenges facing computer science as we
move into the future Bill's been a good
friend of MIT in many different ways for
many years starting next September many
of you are going to be studying and
meeting and eating in the gates building
in the new Ray and Maria Stata Center
many of you already are the recipients
of the work that has been done here at
MIT under our I campus program done it
carried out in collaboration with
Microsoft Research that has really
reinvigorated and reinvented much of
teaching and learning on the MIT campus
but I also want to say in particular
that Bill Gates has been a great
enthusiast for MIT OpenCourseWare
initiative something many of us believe
very deeply in because it is a way of
taking the knowledge and the pedagogy
that is generated here at MIT and making
it accessible to people in other
institutions all around the nation and
throughout the world bill is here today
to talk as I said about the great
challenges facing the future of computer
science but before he comes out I want
to say something quite personally in
addition to the work that we're all here
to hear about today in computer science
and information technology Bill and
Melinda Gates
have done something extraordinarily
wonderful for our planet in the work
that they are sponsoring to improve
health and to eradicate disease
throughout the developing world and
improve the lives of people who live
under conditions that none of us in this
room can even imagine
so please join me in welcoming Bill
Gates
well it's great to be here at MIT mit
has invented so many things and played
such a key role in the advance of
computer science I won't have time to
name them all but Microsoft has been
very privileged to be associated with
MIT in helping collaborate on a number
of projects here
Microsoft is also has some great
employees who came from MIT most notably
people like Gordon Bell who's doing some
still very creative after making so many
contributions and also Butler Lampson
who's actually back here teaching
courses as well as continuing to help
Microsoft the main thing I want to
present today is how I see the next 10
years of computer science as doing some
really amazing things solving some
problems that have been out there for
many decades and transforming most
things of interest transforming the way
people work in businesses the way they
deal with information and meet and
communicate transforming the way that
people at home find information the way
that they create things and connect up
with other people and transform even the
scientists bringing the methodologies of
machine learning and modeling and rich
data mining into all of the hard
sciences and allowing those scientists
to move to the next level it's a paradox
to me that computer science today is
poised to do all these amazing things
and yet in some ways people's
expectation and even the excitement
level about computer science is not as
high today as it was say five years ago
when we were in the midst of what we can
now look back and say was the internet
bubble many of the challenges the
problems the the things that were hard
deliver on during that period are
exactly the kind of things that a
combination of great academic work and
great commercial work coming together
has solved and will make sure that the
productivity advances that we see in the
economy will be dramatically higher more
than double what we received in the
1990s and that's very profound for
innovation employment
many things on a on a global basis the
computer his industry started by making
very big expensive machines and in fact
when I was young people thought of
computers as kind of these daunting
things in the backroom that would often
print out bills that would be wrong and
you could never get corrected people
talked about taking the punch card in
your billing envelope and putting
staples in it or mutilating it to
somehow defeat the big machine and I was
lucky enough to be young at a time when
that changed my friend Paul Allen saw
the very first microprocessor the eight
zeros are eight not very capable but
better than a PDP eight was I mean he
challenged me he said hey bill could you
write software for this could you do a
basic and that really got us going
saying that we wanted to be in on the
ground floor a building the kind of
software that computing would need as it
moved from that back room onto the
desktop as it became a tool of
empowerment a tool for creativity and
communications now it started in a very
humble way the kit computer that Paul
saw on the cover of popular electronics
magazine a freezing cold day in Harvard
Square and brought back to me and said
you know you got a dropout it's
happening without us that machine was
laughable you know it at most had 8k of
memory I had no peripherals so the
software we wrote would flashlights and
do funny things it was a major discovery
that because of the noisiness the
electronics in it that we could actually
put a radio nearby and if we did certain
instruction patterns cause predictable
music to come out of that radio and it
was you know kind of limited what we
could do
that was the beginning and the kind of
excitement around that thinking you know
where could this go that that got our
industry off to a great start there was
a generation of machines that came after
that so-called a machines trs-80
Commodore 64 Apple - all of which
included Microsoft basic in is their
fundamental software was the equivalent
of not only the language but the
operating system everything and you
could type in basic statements to do
graphics and games and business software
and we even gotten discs connected up to
these things we moved away from cassette
tapes and paper tapes to these
ridiculous 8-inch discs that you know
hardly held any information at all
but constant improvement a big milestone
in 1981 was the entry of IBM with the PC
into this business and that had been a
joint project with Microsoft where we'd
convinced them to use the 8086 created
the DOS operating system very limited
system but very appropriate for that
machine and we kicked off an era that
was was fairly different because
starting with that machine we had a
vision that we wanted all the machines
to be compatible that is to use a
software layer to make it so that
whenever you wrote an application it
would run on machines from IBM or HP or
digital equipment or any of the other
computers at the time and that hadn't
been the case and in fact that prevented
the virtuous cycle that we wanted to
have happen it prevented it from getting
going and that cycle was that as more
people saw applications that were
meaningful to them they would buy
machines the more machines were bought
the more volume of components would
happen the lower the cost those
components would be and the more people
would invest in buying applications so
it would make sense to really build a
software industry there essentially was
no software industry before the PC there
were about 20 different companies and
the highest award in the industry was
one that you got for selling a thousand
copies of a piece of software was called
the ICP award and I filled out the
application after we'd sold two million
he's a basic I sent it in and they said
well we'd love to give you this award
but you know there must be some
scientific notation error here you've
got too many zeros and I said no I'm not
kidding
we sold to two million copies and they
said well jeez how come we haven't heard
of you and we said well I don't know
where you been but we do we do have this
very high volume low price models so you
know we're not like on the New York
Stock Exchange or anything but we have
sold two million copies and so personal
computing gained a momentum it gained an
excitement the one of the great issues
was the move from character mode
interface to graphics interface may seem
strange today
you know everyone takes that for granted
but the cycles required the difficulty
of writing these programs made a lot of
people say hey we don't need this that's
just really you know too many icons too
many fonts you know let's stick to the
serious stuff we love these model space
characters up there on the screen and
there were about six or seven years
we're taking some of the pioneering work
from Xerox Apple and Microsoft really
pushed forward with this idea of
graphics interface and that became
Microsoft Windows was integrated in the
operating system and then then we got to
the next frontier that frontier was
connecting all the machines together and
year after year we'd always say emails
coming connectivities coming online
services are coming and in fact it
didn't happen and didn't happen and then
all of a sudden coming out of the
university environment the standards of
the internet exploded along with the
decrease in the cost of optic fiber and
the increase of the speed of the network
and a critical mass was achieved and
that was the period where you know
things definitely went a little crazy
but the goldrush atmosphere actually
accelerated the investment people are
making and raised the awareness that
people had of what a revolutionist was
now some of the things that are hard
about e-commerce or workflow or modeling
or making sure these systems are ultra
reliable ultra secure some of those were
revealed this is shortcomings that
needed software breaks
needed software advances and so as we
look forward it's kind of a bias I have
but the thing that's really going to
make a difference is software it it is a
new generations of software that let us
interact in natural ways that connect
these devices up in new ways and
problems that I see being solved in the
in the near future now the hardware guys
I have to give him credit
they've always provided a more powerful
platform for us to exercise our software
creativity against and that's why Paul
Ally and I could say back in 1975
personal computers will be mainstream
that the slogan we had was a computer on
every desk and in every home and in you
know some small part in some countries
we've come a long ways towards that it's
not yet the machine that we envision in
terms of the ease of use or breadth of
things that can be done but it's
certainly a a good rough draft that's
that's on its way the hardware people
have given us Moore's law that predicts
doubling and chip performance every 18
to 24 months that's held true these last
25 years and you know some something
like the next 10 to 15 years it's very
likely to continue to hold true now that
increase in transistors there are some
very interesting software techniques
related to parallelization that are
needed to take transistor count and map
it into performance it's not automatic
that just because you have twice as many
transistors that you get that
performance and so you know finally some
of these issues of of automatic
parallelization and understanding the
algorithms that let you do that we're
making progress on those the storage
people do an even better job than the
chip people there they're doubling rate
is something like 12 to 18 months and
this is very important because when
storage was expensive the idea that you
could deal with photos and videos and
audio annotation and replicate
information around so it'd be
immediately available even if the
system's not connected up to the network
you know that just wasn't possible
people didn't think in those terms and
in fact you know storage is so available
now we have to be creative in thinking
about what what we're gonna do with that
we're getting lots and lots of that in
fact a good example of how cheap storage
is is that we have this device that
comes out this fall called a portable
Media Center it's a 40 gig disc
beautiful LCD display and you can just
connect this to a PC that's recording TV
shows or how's your movies or you know
whatever's there and it automatically
downloads the movies videos photos onto
this device that you can of course carry
around and use anyway you anywhere you
want and these devices will come out
fairly inexpensive in the four hundred
dollar range and the price will just
come down and down and down because you
know this is the magic of that hardware
innovation eventually we'll just take it
for granted that kids who want to watch
movies or people want to watch shows
have this available and so it won't just
be portable music players but devices
that that deal with the the video as
well the screen is another place where
innovation is critical for us you know
if we think about how we can move
reading from paper to the screen so that
we get the rich searching updating
annotating sharing that the digital
world allows that requires screens with
very high resolution it requires screens
that were comfortable you know holding
in our lap and just sitting there paging
through the information it requires a
thin light device long battery life big
challenges but certainly what's gone on
with LCDs and other screen technology
says that in the future we can assume in
a 30 inch LCD on a knowledge workers
desktop or 322 inch displays which is
the configuration I'm using right now
and you know lets me work with
information in a much better way in the
same way that a newspaper gives you a
big wide field of vision this does that
and
certainly some advances in window
management and use of the screen area
that it has to take place as we get to
extremely high DPI and big screen areas
that that come with this and we believe
that reading will move on to the the
digital platform that the superiority
the cost structure all these things
argue for that as we get devices that
are based on this new screen technology
a nice milestone in that is is the
arrival of the tablet PC that got kicked
off about a year ago it's based on the
miniaturization Hardware the Inc
software ink recognition technology that
we've been working on for over 10 years
is now bootstrapping in terms of the
quality of the hardware learning from
that software or doing that better and
better and in making that mainstream and
so and all the portable devices will
become tablet devices and they really
will be like tablets which they're a
little bit heavier than a tablet today
the graphics processors they're the
improvements are you can get higher
transistor counts there because the
number of duplicated components and
actually if we look to the future of CPU
architecture we can see that more
predicted by what's happening in the GPU
level because they've thought about
parallelization now they do it in a
domain-specific way that we need to open
up but it's really the blending of those
that is the the next stage they're a big
element of course is Wireless as we get
things like ultra wideband Wireless
which is hundreds of megabits the idea
that you connect a computer to the
screen will become obsolete the computer
will find the screen that's nearby and
take advantage but the idea that the
computer and the storage have to be
associated with each other there's no
reason for that you can carry your
storage with you and whatever PC is
around in a very secure way your storage
can be made available to it and you can
be given guarantees that that
information isn't left on that machine
after you log out from that machine so
we'll see the disaggregation of the PC
that way we'll see the arrival of rich
new peripherals you know digital cameras
are now the most popular way to take
photos and now
happening in the motion video space well
those devices will have ultra-wideband
so they'll mark not only the time but
the location of that information and
deliver that to your storage system your
storage system would be a combination of
data stored in the cloud in sort of a
Farsight ocean store type way where you
don't have to worry about whether you've
backed it up because there's many copies
but that are stored in encrypted ways
that that mean that only you have
control of that information or you'll
have the storage that you carry with you
physically that'll give you total
control over making those two things
work well together is very important now
the area of wireless one of the top
challenges has been the cost of
broadband you know when you think about
what's expensive you know getting a PC
saying to rural India you know the
hardware's three or four hundred dollars
the software is less than $50
it's that broadband cost a monthly cost
paying again and again and getting that
infrastructure out there that's really
the prohibitive factor and we believe
through some software techniques around
mesh networks in some advances in the
wireless hardware particularly the WiMAX
type approaches bringing in not just
omnidirectional approaches but
directional antennas as well that we
will get the kind of connectivity that
can make sure that you know connecting
everyone on the planet becomes very
feasible so you'll have a range of
devices wall size screen devices desktop
tablet pocket-sized we even believe in a
a wrist size device in fact I'm wearing
my spot watch which just came out in the
last month and this I don't know if
you've seen it it lets you you know see
sports activities stock prices your
schedule you get messages on it a lot of
different things that are being
transmitted to this watch it was
actually when I was at MIT over ten
years ago that I first saw a
demonstration of FM sideband data
networking and this watch is is based on
that approach of course the modulation
techniques are several generations later
there's a microprocessor in here that we
paid national semiconductor to create
that's based on the ARM architecture
this microprocessor just on my wrist has
ten times the power of the original IBM
PC it's got ten times the memory of the
original IBM PC now this thing is
powerful and of course the battery life
is on the order of many many days
because these things are low power we
can download arbitrary params to this
device so as we get new ideas about
sports presentation information
presentation as people have neat things
they want to do it can come down in an
automatic way today that the watches and
receive only mode but we actually have
the capability to send date as well in a
local area so you can you know find
people common interest a lot of
applications that that glanceable
information platform will be
particularly appropriate for working
with the other devices now we have to
think in terms of scenarios the photo
scenario that you use all the different
devices the scheduling scenario using
all those devices and it's way too hard
today to get those things to work
together one of the big places that
software advances will change thing is
change things in the way is the way
business is done the information
visibility that a typical information
worker has is extremely low they're used
to it to way so they don't know to
complain but their ability you know say
somebody gives them a sales printout
they look at these numbers and they you
know they must think wow that one's
really big what do we do now that one's
kind of small cheese are we in trouble
well their ability to just dive into
that data and see it by time period
product cost structure they don't have
it it's not there that the scheming
ization and model approach to bring that
down to every employee to just naturally
expect that they can see those things
and understand those things that's not
their you know the world the business
intelligence hasn't delivered on that
the xml file
detian that's advanced so fantastically
over these last six years is the
foundation to make that happen
to build xml into the spreadsheet to
build a knowledge business processes so
you can visually see what's the state of
this activity businesses today do all
these custom modifications to the
applications programs they run the
enterprise applications and it's very
strange because the difference is
between those businesses you ought to be
able to express it in some other way
other way than code you know code is
complex when people update the
applications you don't know how to
combine that new code with the other
code because it's not orthogonal you
know there shouldn't be code in that
process there should just be visual
business processes that you're
connecting up to and explaining how this
business is different than this business
you know how does the order process work
how does the collection process work how
does the analysis process work and
that's kind of thing we're really on the
verge of because xml gets our semantic
level up and lets us finally address
making this information really available
if we look at meetings meetings are a
source of a lot of inefficiency any
information worker will tell you you
know things that they didn't need to be
there for things they meetings he had to
fly in to that they would have preferred
to be able to do at a distance things
that didn't get followed up on things
that somebody who wasn't there you
wanted to explain to them that you
couldn't just link in and see the
transcript or see the video of what went
on there well storage is almost free and
cameras and software to scan and
understand this stuff will be almost
free and so we can take the meeting and
have that be something that we bring a
lot of efficiency to you know if you if
you make meetings in general 10 percent
more efficient that's tens of billions
of dollars of extra productivity every
year and that can be used just as cost
savings it can be used to make better
decisions to drive quality into
processes and it will do every one of
those things even the basic process of
buying and selling hasn't been been made
as efficient as it should be can you
find all the sellers
particular can you check their
reputation can you if you engage in a
transaction see the state of that
transaction in a very rich way if your
computer's talking to their computer and
their computer is somehow malicious are
you protected from that kind of behavior
if the software's talking to the other
software what about the workers you know
say that there's a delivery that's
defective how do you coordinate the
negotiation on email in an ad hoc way
with these back-end systems so they can
understand things and check the state of
things these things are incredibly
inefficient today's so basic workflow is
not built in e-commerce has not happened
ecommerce only really happens where
every seller can find every buyer every
buyer can find every seller independent
of location or previous knowledge of
each other and that rich transaction is
done in a a pure digital way in
communications and what we got today is
kind of a hodgepodge of different things
you know the latest thing is blogging
that comes after instant messaging which
comes after email you've got your
wireless phone your wired phone a lots
of times you're interrupted the phone
rings when you don't want it things come
in to your inbox you don't want and your
time is a scarce resource and so these
activities are wasting your time causing
a lack of productivity even in some
cases you have enough spam that you
filter out or I don't have time to read
mail that would have been a value now
for me spam you know it's this awful
thing but sometimes when I look at these
fams I get I have to just step back and
laugh about them I've got a few examples
here this is one of my first ones
[Laughter]
and it's clear once I get out of debt
I'm gonna be meeting a lot of nice
people we're gonna be friendly to me the
next one looked like might be more
targeted and this is not one that any of
you need worry about since I hope you
you won't drop out and finally there was
one that really related to a serious
cost problem I've got and that you know
the shareholders really want me to dig
into this one I understand what's going
on there so it's it's a serious problem
but it's amazing the things that are out
there letting people send billions of
pieces of mail very very cheaply you
know D values the time of the person on
the other end and this is a very
solvable problem we need mail that comes
from people we communicate with
regularly to be authenticated both and
we announced on Tuesday a way of doing
that leveraging off the DNS that we
think can be applied and used as a
standard literally within months mail
that comes in from a stranger some type
of proof is necessary if the filter
thinks that looks like spam then you
need some type of proof to distinguish
it from the other email and there's
several forms of proof that will be used
and they all work in parallel any any
one of them it's kind of an or condition
proof that's computational where you
solve one of these problems that's
asymmetric in the opposite way that
cryptographic functions are that is it's
asymmetric in the sense that checking
the answer is easy but actually doing
the computation is hard and so for
somebody sending a modest amount of mail
it'll just happen in background they
won't notice it but if you were sending
millions of emails it would be a
significant computation cost to do that
so you you screen out human interactive
proof where you bounce back and make
somebody saw that something that
software alone can't do is is
another approach or if there's
connection into a payment system making
somebody put a little bit of money at
risk not that gets charged them and this
is only email from strangers but that is
at risk so that if it really is junk the
person who receives it and spends time
reading it at least they get the benefit
that whatever the threshold they set for
their time their inbox rate that gets
credited to them but if it's their
long-lost brother or somebody saying
their house is on fire
hopefully they won't debit that they'll
say okay that was just at risk and I I'm
glad that person can't connect it up to
me in the home environment when we think
about media and memories there's so much
that can be done and yet we're gonna
have to deal with a lot of volume you
know all the music you like all the
movies that you're interested in all
those photos that you take it's kind of
amazing we have a researcher at at
Microsoft Research who wears as they go
around in the day something that's just
a camera and it notices when there's a
big scene change or when there's people
laughing or anything loud or something
and it takes photos so at the end of the
day that researcher has over a hundred
photos that might be interesting to put
in her journal and and save and even
annotate with some voice or something
but you know software has got to help
select which one of those things are
interesting and to to navigate amongst
those things and and so there's a lot
that has to be done on that we want to
put users in control in the home you
know this idea of watching TV shows only
on a schedule slowly but surely that's
going away you know people use that
whether it's built into what we call the
media center PC or a Tebow or the
satellite receiver get very addicted to
it it's kind of like email where you
know it's not perfect but you don't want
to give it up you just want it to get
better and so as we think about that we
think about you know what kind of
interfaces would would deliver on that
and in fact I've got just real quickly a
couple prototypes from Microsoft
research I wanted to to give you just a
sense of this in fact these were both
done by MIT graduate
it's the first one here is pretty
straightforward let's say you're looking
at movies you're looking at Blade Runner
here and what it shows is okay the
directors Ridley Scott well then I can
go over here and see other movies
directed by Ridley Scott and I just
select one of those alien that's brought
to the center and of course then all the
things related to that come out and I
can see okay these actors and see the
different things they were in and see if
you know one of those might be
interesting and just pivot through these
sets of movies in a simple visual way of
course this will be annotated with the
reviews that you trust comments from
friends you know if you've seen the
movie what you thought about it and so
very navigable to get around the the
movies of interest the other one I
wanted to show up has to do with photos
and photos we're dealing with you know
lots and lots of photos literally you
know if you take your lifetime tens of
thousands of photos that you and your
friends are sharing and you you'd like
to be able to get back to in a rich way
and so here we see them as miniatures I
can just you know hover over these
things lots of photos we've even mixed
in video clips as well here's you know
Gordon Bell at the computer museum
because we don't think the boundary
between Stills and motion will hold up
in fact you know these audio comments
that we call photo stories bring a lot
more emotional connection to that
experience and so in that you know it's
just like this you know it's hard to
find exactly what you want and so people
will take these things with keywords
here's things that relate to
Thanksgiving we can do software analysis
and so if we're you know we want the
photos with theses we just select those
if you want the photos that are indoors
the software can select those if we want
the outdoor photos we can select those
if we want to see photos that are
similar you know let's select this
bridge photo and say okay you know what
I can relax the constraint and say well
it's similar to that okay that's a lot
like it that's a little bit more like it
and I can select groups of things to be
used this software automatically when it
brought the photos in helped orient the
photo by being able to recognize the
cases where things were
at least though the software looked like
they might be miss oriented we can also
start to use a 3d way of looking at
these things to group these things and
what that means like you know now this
is by timeline so I can select a set and
take these I can change the timeline get
to finer groups in terms of when they
were taken or where they were taken and
this makes it very easy to just step
through these but also deal with groups
that I want to organize and take in
different ways so in general sense we
can say well that's just a database but
we need much better ways of interacting
with the database than just the common
query processor
you know people won't be writing SQL
statements to navigate through their
photos now this optimism might have
about computer science and its impact a
little bit the the proof of how serious
we are about that is the R&D spending
that has been increasing at Microsoft
today its 6.8 billion a year
it's kind of an intimidating number at
least to me since ten years from now
people say to me whether that was wise
or or not but I you know I'm quite
confident that it is that's the largest
technology R&D budget that there is iBM
is about 20% less than that
but of course not all focused on
software and then other commercial
entities you'd have a big drop down
particularly if you take the long term
component the Microsoft the equivalent
of Microsoft Research we actually do our
research work in three different
locations in Cambridge and in our
headquarters and in Beijing we have
smaller groups on some other areas but
those are the primary areas we've had a
as I mentioned earlier a strong
collaboration on a number of things with
MIT for example the AI campus project
we're a key partner in that you know I
I'm you know thrilled with the things
that are coming out of that some
involved the learning at a distance some
involved the tablet PC you know the idea
that we can make learning better there's
no doubt and I think that's a great
pioneering project natural interfaces
that's this magic paper idea that's a
fantastic thing and we've gotten
involved in things that think we've got
a lot of people on the faculty here that
are helping drive our agenda for example
Victor's who's on the technical advisory
board for our group over in Beijing so
it's been a good strong relationship and
the progress being made in the
combination of academia and commercial
research labs is really fascinating it's
it's phenomenal and it and it's not
getting that much visibility and yet
these advances are extremely relevant to
problems that that we have the problems
that are of critical importance
take for example security and of course
MIT is a strong program and on that of
course we've got professor Rivest who
just got the the Turing award which is a
fantastic thing security is something
that if we're going to achieve that
potentially these systems has to get a
lot better and that's a tough thing
because code reliability gets into that
how you configure up these systems how
you watch behavior as part of that so
it's going to take some breakthroughs
over 25 years ago when I was leaving
Harvard this idea of proving program
correctness was sort of invoked and
unfortunately for many years although
there was some progress the scale of the
program it could be applied against
didn't get very large hundreds of lines
of code now working with universities
people in Microsoft Research are taking
literally things that are a million
lines of code and being able to go in
and prove very important things about
those programs or if they can't prove
them they're able to show the counter
example that says yes this can touch
memory that it shouldn't touch or it can
acquire the lock and never release the
lock and so you see exactly what the
pattern is and how to fix that now all
this proving technology is having a
wonderful effect on innovation in
programming languages because we want to
take everything that the parameter knows
about the data types and the constraints
and express those in as high a level a
strong
fashion as we can through contracts and
this idea of expressing the contracts
very easily
having languages that are very explicit
about those things you know that takes
all the theory of language innovation
and brings it into the mainstream you
know and says we really need those those
capabilities keeping systems up-to-date
being able to look at a system and say
is its behavior normal we need this both
at the at the single computer level and
looking at the network is there a type
of traffic that's exploded in terms of
usage at a time where the overall
traffic is starting to be too heavy for
the network to deal with there should be
automatic tools out there that are doing
that and in fact mature machine learning
techniques that build a model of typical
behavior and then see these things that
are unusual will be used at every level
of the system the memory management
level at the API level at the network
sending level and at the the wide
network monitoring level and that we
call that behavior blocking and that
that'll be a critical component in
solving those security issues another
set of areas that I think are making
wonderful progress are getting a more
natural interface between users on the
computer you know victor zue here has
been a big advocate of that building
some wonderful systems that take speech
all the way up into particulars and let
people interact with those and making it
so that it's a not a huge technical
exercise to build one of those systems
that you just have a general runtime for
that I think is something that will be
solved in the years ahead the Prioress
and speech recognition is very good if
you take a isolated simplistic case
where there's no context and no noise
and a perfect microphone three great
simplifications the difference between a
human and a computer is not very drastic
it says we relaxed those constraints and
bring in context crummy microphones and
noise that then the divergence between
the computer and the and the human is
quite substantial
and of course human users of these
things are very demanding because speech
doesn't operate at a conscious level as
it makes mistakes you just get irritated
and talk louder and of course it's been
trained it's learned you're speaking in
normal tone so it just gets worse and
worse and so it just D generates while
you're yelling at the system now ink is
not quite the same it's a little easier
because you processing at a conscious
level and so although it's irritating
when it doesn't work you can look and
say well hmm could I have recognized
that you know is that e loops so closely
that it looks like a C and in fact as we
monitor people using our handwriting
system the plasticity is partly in our
subsystem but it's a lot of it's in the
user that the user consciously or
subconsciously is actually writing more
explicitly the features that have caused
the the problem in the past so that's
one where that's partly why ink is
coming into the mainstream say a few
years in terms of general input the
equivalent of dictation a little bit
faster the place we're seeing our speech
work really catch on is a combination of
people where the keyboard is
unattractive for them for any reason
including repetitive stress injury or
people in China and Japan or Korea where
the keyboard is relatively less
effective as an input technique we can
already beat that fastest typist of
Chinese with a Chinese speech
recognition system and so you know
that's a milestone along the way that is
pretty exciting
general artificial intelligence this is
the Holy Grail and when I was talking to
faculty today I was impressed that mit
has kept its commitment to this area you
know throughout all the years and and it
is one where some very interesting
approaches statistical approaches
Bayesian approaches how are now starting
to be used in different fad in different
fashions the actual product on the
market that it apparently is a spin-off
related to a professor here's this the
thing that goes around in vacuums the
rug and that's pretty low-level better
than nothing but we you know we
want to move up in terms of other things
that go on for gaming one place we're
using our our machine learning
technology a lot is we on xbox live can
watch player behavior in different
strategies and the machine can learn and
so if you want to pick an opponent
typically the if you play the computer
historically it's a it's a road
algorithm that you know isn't that much
fun to play because it it eventually you
see that as being very predictable we
can take all the play styles that we're
seeing across this network and create
any sort of level of difficulty or
different fashion of play and you know
make it as as interesting and as varied
as playing with human opponents
including letting you win every once in
a while which is video games for me that
is pretty tough you know you pick these
things up and they are geared to well to
to you and not to people haven't haven't
used them nearly as much and so will
make these things appeal and even if you
start to beat the system boy will crank
it up to a level that will that will
keep it challenging so AI is going to be
applied in a lot of different ways
modeling things and the other sciences
have been with dynamic behavior and
systems very very important all the
natural interface techniques vision and
speech will come to take those for
granted in a very strong way now the
boundary between computer science and
the other sciences historically was a
fairly hard boundary and that is
breaking down one great example of that
it's a research we have Jim Gray who
looked at astronomy and said boy there's
a lot of data there and a lot of the
advances come in in proposing something
that you can either validate by looking
at that data or invalidate and so we
really need to get all these databases
connected together and the the semantics
in are very high level that's again not
just a relational problem but
collaborating with a lot of astronomers
who know the domain
he's been hooking up those databases and
now navigating through this logical law
connected database as a very important
tool in astronomy and many of the
sciences are going to where those those
data rich data collections are necessary
for everyone to have access to in a
high-level way biology of course is
perhaps one of the most challenging
because of the breadth and the
differences in the data but even there
this is starting to happen and you know
I had a great discussion with some of
the faculty who were pushing off in that
direction and really seen that the
boundary of computer science and biology
are very much coming together and we
need people who understand both of those
things to make advances in solving
diseases and I'm very optimistic about
how fast that will move forward now this
tool that we've got that PC connected to
the Internet and all this great
empowerment it's such an important thing
that we do have to worry that there are
people who are benefiting from this and
people are not and people talk about
that as the digital divide it's
something that I think people in
computer science should care a lot about
and in various ways contribute to trying
to minimize that difference one of the
the projects that Microsoft got involved
with together with my foundation was
saying well what about libraries would
it be appropriate to have computers
there and we were a little worried about
this because you know with the librarian
like it you know would it be at the
expense of the books would kids come in
and just hack up the machines would
would they be doing enriched mean things
as they were using those computers it
was it was unclear but six years ago we
kicked it off we did pilot projects and
over six years in all 50 states in
18,000 libraries you know rule
everywhere in the country we put in over
50,000 computers and the response of
librarians was just phenomenal of
wanting to be trained wanting to
reinforce the the role of that library
and traffic to the library increased not
just to come use the computer but also
the number of books that were being lent
out and we were able to monitor and
support all these things and
very efficient way that made it work
very well you know throughout the
project we learned things you know we
came up with a version of the software
you can just hit a button to switch from
Spanish to English for a lot of these
libraries we had a button you can just
hit to switch to big print so if you
don't like reading the fonts that we
typically use boom all of a sudden it's
a lot a lot better and we came up with
things to help people with the common
scenarios and so you know it's great to
see if you give people those tools
they'll use them then they it really
makes a big difference for them getting
these tools out to schools getting them
out to all different countries a lot of
challenges remain there that I need need
to be addressed we think about computer
science one thing computer science is
done through the internet through
software's made the world a smaller
place in fact you know people now worry
that this is going to create a new level
of global competition and the answer is
it is people's opportunity to have great
jobs in the future will be far more
determined by their level of education
than by what country they happen to be
in historically it didn't matter your
education level didn't matter that much
if if you were in a rich country you you
made a lot of money and if you were in a
poor country made very little money now
the opportunity for educated people
worldwide to help out to contribute to
products not just software products but
anything you can imagine
architecture law answering the phone you
know it will be done where people have
those skills and as people look at that
they go wow what what does that mean
well it means the US has to keep its
edge in terms of doing the best work and
that means research means intellectual
property it means improving the
education system you know rededication
it's very similar to what happened in
the 1980s when there was a lot of angst
about Japan Japan at the time appeared
to have a model where they would just
pick an industry the Karnes tree the
computer industry the consumer
electronics industry and boom they would
they would do it better and the great
thing that happened in the eighties is
there's a lot of humility a lot of
thinking well do we just match what
they do exactly that way or do we just
push forward on our strengths our
approach to things you know during the
80s they did this AI project and and it
really because of the way it was done it
wasn't dominant the diverse academic
approach that we use here it really
ended up in not generating much so we
rededicate ourselves and it's actually
the work done during that period that
led to that productivity increase that
that benefited all countries but the
u.s. in particular during the 1990s
you know I say that I see that same
thing repeating itself as we question
our unique role and reinforce what needs
to be done one challenge that we have in
the field in all science fields but
particularly in computer science is the
issue of diversity you know to do the
best work we want to draw on everybody's
talent and give everybody a deep
involvement
you know the variety of jobs the need
the need for great people is pretty
phenomenal and the diversity numbers in
some professions like law and medicine
have been going pretty strongly in the
favorable direction one thing I
personally gotten involved with to try
and help push this forward it's a
scholarship program that's called the
the Gates Millennium Scholarship and
here at MIT out of out of actually a
thousand people who get those
scholarships 60 people are here at MIT
so it's a great thing and a real
endorsement of MIT that there are more
Gates
Scholars at this school than at any
other school you know these science
problems are tough but they're fun to
work on the jobs that are involved with
them are you know you can have an impact
you can work work with other people it's
not just somebody isolated off coding
all night although if you want to do
that that's fine we still have lots of
jobs that are like that
and so the the the sense of reward being
involved in changing business change in
entertainment changing education you
know giving tools to those new science
Sciences including Talpa disease I
that's a phenomenal opportunity and so
that's why I'm more excited about
computer science than ever and I'm very
excited to see what some of you here can
do taking that to the next level thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much and do me a favor
have your question end with a question
mark so it should actually be a question
and try and keep it as short as you can
and then when you're done go take your
seat and give bill a chance to answer it
you're up could you explain to me dotnet
I've seen a lot a lot of things about
dotnet never really understood what it
does what it you know actually
accomplishes well the there's a
revolution in how information is
represented around XML and that's
something that we in a few small
companies got behind now seven or eight
years ago and in the year 2000 we said
we were really betting our company on
taking those XML representations and
having some protocols around them that
have are now called the Web Services
protocols making those standards
standards that would exist on any
operating system any language and
letting those be the basis for deep
interoperability for applications like
e-commerce that I talked about and so
dotnet is us embracing XML embracing web
services and building that into the
Windows platform and it means building
web services and XML into Excel building
it into the sequel server database
having windows use that to be the way
that you set it up and manage it so that
management isn't a set of protocols or
approaches or api's that are separate or
off to the side so bringing net to all
of our products and connecting it up
this way is is something that's a very
broad project that we're about 60% of
the way done with and when we made that
bet it looked like a very risky bet but
I have to say at this point with the
cooperation on the web services
standards the
around XML it's not not a bet that's
risky at all at this point Thanks thank
you coming if you were 19 years old
again and let's say this time around
today you're at MIT and Microsoft was
already founded would you continue your
education or and/or create like a new
company and what type of company and why
well I I loved going to school it was he
didn't go to MIT but it you know it was
very similar there were very smart
people around to talk to every day they
fed you every day you know you didn't
have to go to classes if you worked a
little bit they'd give you this positive
reinforcement these grades every once in
a while to encourage you and so what had
happened was my friend Paul Allen who
saw this microprocessor and really egged
me on had come out to Boston and taken a
job out here at Honeywell to say to me
every day it's time to start our company
it's time to start a company well he
didn't succeed until he had that cover
of popular electronics and said it's
gonna it's gonna start without us let's
be the first and so then officially I
didn't leave school I went on leave you
know I'm still on leave in fact when
Harvard has my name in their
publications they always put 77 after it
as though you know as though I graduated
which of course I I didn't and so I'd
say that you know if I was a student
today I'd certainly be you know looking
for some paradigm shift that could make
a dramatic change I don't know if I'd
work in AI computation by computational
biology those are two that you know I
really love and I'm glad to hear those
are there's a strong increase in
emphasis and those things here at MIT
but I'd say that anyone who has in mind
you know a deep paradigm shift for an
industry go ahead you know take the risk
go away for a couple years and you know
MIT will probably let you come back if
it wasn't the paradigm shifting thing
that you'd hoped it would be thank you
many people consider you an inspiration
who is your personal hero I have many
heroes people that I've I've been lucky
enough to work with you know from my
parents too a lot of the people at
Microsoft one that I'd really highlight
is Warren Buffett his way of you know
looking at the world looking at how
business should be done showing that you
can have fun while doing a very
important tough job
he's had an incredible influence on me
and you know it's part of the reason I
say hey I have the best job in the world
because I can I've had a chance to meet
somebody like Warren and and get his
advice and his humor which is is really
really unique please I how do you feel
about software patents and their role in
either promoting or stifling innovation
and are you concerned about them
long-term
I know that Microsoft got sued like we
got sued it's interesting because we're
on I'm really both sides of this patent
thing we because of our success or a
target for patents some of them not as
good as they should be and we're also a
company that files lots and lots of
patents we file more software patents
than any other company the patent system
is not perfect and I think you know any
freshman could look at the patent system
and suggest improvements to the patent
system but it's a system that has worked
amazingly well you know despite its
mistakes and its problems over several
hundred years you know starting with
Benjamin Franklin the kind of incentives
for invention you know the creation of
the biotechnology field is that a good
thing the pharmaceutical industry is
that a good thing these are industries
that the u.s. leads in and
created immense improvement in human
welfare and all based on just taking the
patent system as it was and using it so
that as they would do innovative work
there would be some some incentive there
and so you know I think we absolutely
can improve the patent system but it's
something that is important and
particularly if we look at global
competition the things that you know
generate jobs here helped us be a strong
leader a lot of that is that if we're
super innovative there's a reward that
goes with it
Thanks so there's a really interesting
trend that I think you started to touch
on but he didn't dive very fully into
which is the commoditization of software
and software innovation and what I was
wondering was how do you see Microsoft
kind of fitting into a world where you
know software is cheap and produced a
very low cost and what do you have to
say to your current and prospective
fleet of software engineers current
current and prospective fleet of soft
rain oh great well then yes
Swampert has this interesting property
that unfortunately it never wears out
and so when we sell somebody a copy of
Windows and office they can just use it
you know forever and they don't owe us a
dime it's there as they get to use it
and so all we get paid ever it's not
like Coke where they get thirsty again
that's a good business
but it's not as fun to be in a business
like that all we get paid for is our
breakthroughs we have to come up with a
version of office that's worth licensing
worth installing worth learning we're
dealing with some you know effect that
might have or it it might you know
change things and that's our economic
proposition versus all the free software
that's out there all the installed base
of our best work of the years past
that's out there and people aren't don't
have to pay us a thing for we have to
innovate enough that it's worthwhile to
license now there's another way to look
at it though which is if you take a
knowledge worker most anywhere even in
Bangalore and Hyderabad you know they're
making you know $40,000 a year they've
got an office they've got phone bills
they've even got paper clips what we're
saying to people is hey pay us less than
$100 a year for the right of that person
to have the very best software the very
best software to communicate create
collaborate organize their things so
it's a percentage of let it cost you to
have that information worker to have the
very up-to-date the very best software
is it worth something less than a you
know a hundred dollars a year to do that
and you know that's that's the when we
hire people we say hey if you don't
think we can do that
you shouldn't join because that's what
the standard were held to every year and
so far we've done okay
and certainly the customers when I meet
with customers I never been in a meeting
where they say you're done you're done
you know they say hey your stuff isn't
easy enough to administer it's not
secure enough it doesn't do this feature
it doesn't let us do this customization
that we need so the need for better
software and the impact of better
software is is super super high and the
fact that we've created this high-volume
low-cost model you know works very well
the fact that once we solve workflow
there's hundreds of millions of people
who will benefit from that once we get
the spreadsheet up to this modeling
level hundreds of millions of people who
will benefit from that
it's a model that you know has worked
and that I believe in you gave us a
broad overview of many different aspects
of where you see things going in the
future I wanted to focus on the digital
divide where how did you or there are a
lot of people with with money that don't
do nearly as much as you do I'm
wondering why you found that very
important if there was a specific
experience and what's your concrete
vision for Microsoft and for your
foundation for bridging that divide
between you know the US and other
countries around the world developing
countries Microsoft is its philanthropy
focuses really in two areas one is that
whatever causes our employees believe in
we match their donations so if they want
to give to MIT you know they want to
give to some local church whatever
nonprofit we match that including they
can take company software and provide
that at extremely low cost the other
thing is the other focus is digital
divide and this means going to every
country and thinking about how can we
get computers to be available it means
the Boys and Girls Club thing we've done
in the u.s. the library thing we've done
in the US there's a group called empower
that provides software to nonprofits and
lets them do those things so for
Microsoft it's very much digital divide
my foundation is a little little bit
different and and for Microsoft why do
we do it well our employees love it you
know it speaks to our mission of
empowerment that it's not just
empowerment for people or wealthy it's
empowerment empowerment for everyone so
it's a great morale thing they get
deeply involved and and it builds
relationships with governments and other
people we want to work with for me
personally the focus is a little broader
because I didn't want my clan to be to
be just you know related to that one
thing and I thought I wouldn't do
philanthropy until I was old I thought
okay I'm gonna work and make money and
then I'll stop doing that and then I'll
give money away
and I knew I was going to give it away
because I don't believe that passing
substantial sums of money to your
children is necessarily good for them
they may not agree in fact there's one
story about that where I was in bed this
weekend at 7:00 in the morning and my
daughter comes in and wakes me up and
says dad dad I was using the computer
you got to come I said can I just keep
using the computer it's okay no you got
to come I won some money and so we went
of course it was one of those contests
you know that you really hadn't won any
money they wanted to visit the website
you know made me think T's got to get
rid of that stuff but yeah so I've
chosen that my resources are going to go
back to society and in the the best way
that I can come up with and that's
turned out to really be two things one
is World Health that's the biggest thing
that's in my view the most urgent
problem in the world at large
very unaddressed I could speak for days
about that and then second is the
biggest problem in this country which is
education and that's where the library
program and the Gates Millennium
Scholarship Program comes out of that
and because of the urgency of those two
problems I've ended up doing something I
didn't expect to do which is you know
I'll have some days where part of the
day I'm trying to make money and then
part of the day I'm giving it away so
far it hasn't made me schizophrenic to
try and bridge those two two bones yes
my question relating to security I guess
it's a great responsibility and a big
challenge to my question is most in
Toronto I guess a recent paper by dr.
Gere about the monoculture of Windows
thank you guys are so popular that you
know basically if there's a security
problem a lot of people have it first do
you think that that is a problem and
second what kind of solutions do you
guys think should be applied to that
well it um it is not you know if you say
okay you're there's there's two types of
security things that go on there's
people who want Fame and they like to
attack the most popular system and as we
get down the learning curve of making it
so they don't succeed that actually
deals with the most serious security
threat the serious security threat is
not somebody who's --ml it just wants
pain and somebody really wants to steal
information and so as we beat that the
fame oriented IQ drive that regularity
down we actually create will create the
first system that's truly secure that is
tested by lots and lots of IQ and come
up with much richer methodologies that
allow that to work and so you know
there's breakthrough ideas that come out
of research and universities that are
allowing us to get to that extremely
secure point it's a process of a number
of years looking forward the approach
where you say hey let's have you know
how many operating systems do you want
fifty a hundred that just says to a
company hey your salary data's on a
hundred different operating systems and
applications people have to try and
write software for a hundred different
operating systems oops
now you can't buy the same applications
that would be a monoculture you've got
to buy a hundred different word
processors and everybody has to learn
those but they don't exchange data but
what's the security statement all you
need is one bug in one of the hundred
operating systems or one of the hundred
word processors and your your salary
data is out to the world variety just
say V equals variety V increases the the
threat area it may slow down the idea of
these spreading functions that are done
for fame but it doesn't make information
any more secure so what does the world
need the world needs a small number of
operating systems that are that have
firewalling
techniques and isolation techniques and
verification techniques that makes them
secure and in a sense we're on the
fastest learning curve moving to that
it's the most urgent thing we're doing
and it's you know I bar Rd that's
several been in a year just focused on
that challenge and so you know variety
is not the answer
technology and the investments were
making or what what drive towards that
answer I'm sorry to say we have time for
me one more question so please make it
one that Bill Gates has never heard
before
yeah wow that's a pretty tough my guess
is a finance question
Microsoft currently has around fifty
billion dollars in cash equivalents or
short-term securities a number that's
gonna reach about a hundred billion in a
few years
what do you see Microsoft doing with
that money or how do you justify holding
that much cash I sleep well at night no
it was actually a very serious question
and one that we have the interesting
thing about software is it's not really
based on building a lot of factories or
you know buying a lot of materials and
going back to the early days of
Microsoft Microsoft has been profitable
you know we never had an internet
business model it's ironic that we
actually took the company public at all
because we never that money is still
sitting in our bank account we never
spent a dime of that money it was really
just to get the incentive system for the
employees which you know his net has
been more generous than any incentive
system that any company has ever done
and so I you know it that was a good
thing in that dimension but it wasn't to
raise capital and so we've accumulated
capital we've done buybacks over the
years I think we've spent you know what
30 billion on buybacks over the years
we've instituted a dividend that was
modest at first then we doubled it it's
still fairly modest and as we're moving
forward we do need to continually
evaluate this we've tried to manage the
investments and the money very well but
they'll come a point where we either
through buyback or dividend or you know
whatever other approach might exist we
probably will change the balance sheet
of the company and make it more pure
what we're all about is one thing
developing software and you know we want
when people buy our stock or think about
our company you know that should be it
it should be about how we invest our
Treasury thing or you know anything else
just about are we is there that
opportunity in software and are we we
the company seizing it thank you and
thank you for your questions
the bill thank you very much and of
course you can't leave MIT without your
very own MIT sweatshirt right and and we
know that probably every University
gives you a sweatshirt but we're the
only one that's also going to give you a
hardhat and on the front as a picture of
the way mhm gates building taken a few
minutes ago we're a good help thank you
[Applause]